[Musique]
oh
pourquoi nous
cet artiste d'un voulu mais transcend
déplacent en europe ce sont des tableaux
pièges donc piégé c'est à dire attraper
les choses alors d'habitude c'est plutôt
pour les animaux hélas et piéger les
objets les gestes enfin brisé tous qui a
servi juste au repas et les fixer
définitivement
[Musique]
pourquoi aussi lydia douce on est tous
ces petits chemins qu'ont jour et ben
dhia ils ont déjà mangé
ouais alors que celle qui est au sol eh
ben ils viennent juste mais keita voilà
c'est un peu pour expliquer pour dire
voilà au départ c'est bien rangée
préparer la table les invités arrivent
et puis à la fin du repas la réalité
elle est toute différente
c'est un peu comme si on faisait une
photographie tu vois de ce moment juste
très court qui est la fin du repas ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que tous et à
l'eau puisqu'il emploie le terme de
tableau ça fait référence à la peinture
quand tu vois il ya des artistes qui ont
très souvent représenté ce qu'on appelle
les natures mortes quand un esprit c'est
ça il pense aussi au tableau doit delà
de du 16e siècle ont lancé de la
peinture ancienne
parce qu'en fait on représente les
choses sur une toile et là au contraire
on prend la chose quelques années et on
l'a fait un tableau ce qui est
intelligent
c'est un peu bizarre pour les gens qui
étaient dans la rue le voir comme une
langue ou à travers la vitrine envoyait
déjà engagés dans la galerie donc il a
organisé sept dans une galerie à la à
milan et est réellement s'avère que ce
côté un peu provocateur
[Musique]
tous les tableaux c'est tout tout ce
qu'il a fait à manger c'est lui télé qui
fait kiffer café chaque fois la cuisine
laisser un jour un jour c'est la cuisine
pour le poisson bleu l'un d'eux mêmes ou
deux jours après il fait la cuisine pour
le verso tu vois ce n'était pas le même
jour oui et c'était tout le temps avec
exemple les codis contenant la table
pour ça que ça s'appelle tableaux pièges
astro gastronomique
[Musique]
m